hey robbie how you doing
hey morgan good how are you i am good so
i love a good horror movie and this one
freaked me out like i was closing my
eyes
through half of it which is a good sign
for me that it's a good horror movie oh
no that's a good sign for sure yeah it's
a really good sign um but i want to know
you know now that you've been trained to
fight zombies how would you
in real life handle
being thrown into raccoon city
oh
um
not unlike chris redfield does um
you know it's one of those things where
he doesn't know what it is until he's
too deep to leave so you know you got to
fight your way out um
in a version where
he knows what's going on and none of his
friends or family are in danger
i probably just hit the road
bye
okay who out of the cast do you think
would do really well in raccoon city uh
evan and tom think together as a team
they would do well they compared
themselves to pinky in the brain i think
evan is the brain uh but who do you
think would do like really well in
raccoon city
my money's on me i'm i've watched enough
and played enough zombie things to be
very confident in the zombie apocalypse
i'll tell you one thing i'm in a condo
downtown or like
not out not too far from downtown
toronto and i would be getting the hell
out of here
yeah
okay so then and you can throw whoever
you want on the bus
who do you think would not do well
out of the cash
why
i don't know i just feel like she's gone
she's just
just dead
right away
not putting up with that i think oh it's
keep going
no she would just like she'd have
something funny to say and she's like a
really thing and then they should the
zombies would just eat her in the mirror
nice yeah they don't take kindly to
humor um
tom
yeah yeah you know what i can see that
don't he doesn't have time for it he'd
be like
whatever come on
let's get this over with um you know
it's so cool when you think of resident
evil you either played the games or
you've seen the movies you know the
first game came out in 1996 what is it
about resident evil that we always want
more
no i mean i was only eight when i played
the first game i probably shouldn't have
been playing the first game but i'll
have to take that up with my parents i
guess they can't really
you know they have an excuse now
considering i'm in the movie but um
i you know one of my earliest childhood
video game memories is sitting in the
dark playing
resident evil and the dogs jumping
through the window and scaring the
living
hell out of me and
i think i think people like i mean
obviously people like to get scared or
be scared when they know that they're
actually safe you know amusement parks
haunted houses horror movies
people like the thrill
while still knowing that they are not in
any actual danger
that's true do you like watching horror
movies or do you prefer playing [ __ ]
themed games
a little bit of both i like i like
horror movies in in like a communal
situation i like i like watching them
with people
yeah having shot horror movies it kind
of sucks the fun out of watching them a
little bit i've seen behind the curtain
um but but i you know i like to see see
people react my my wife watches them
like this
that's like me
she she squints her eyes closes again so
she can only see a little bit and she
plugs her ears completely and i'm like
at this point why why bother
why'd you buy a ticket
no i'm the same way it's something
because the music's so good at like
scares that i i plug and then i'll watch
i don't squint as much but i have to
plug so and i feel weirdly in control
that way i don't know but i love it
okay i got issues okay fine um
you know when it when it comes to so so
that was actually going to be my next
question like it's so fun for the
audience to watch it um but how intense
was shooting this film
do you have a ghost in your
room my dog she decided to throw her
bone off the couch in that exact moment
um how intense was shooting this film
um you know
it wasn't it wasn't because like it
would be scary and then they'd yell cut
and then the zombie would like drink a
coke and you're like okay well
that's not very scary um but the great
thing was most of the zombies were were
stunt men and women in zombie makeup so
when we were shooting the action scenes
it was easier to get you know a little
more aggressive and not worry about
hurting another actor and nobody nobody
falls harder than than stunt players so
you know they were making us look
really badass and uh and that just made
things a lot more fun on my end yeah
well i mean there's so many moments that
are really fun about this movie how much
fun did you have this cast
cast was great i mean especially given
we were shooting during a pandemic like
things things were definitely not normal
but we were bubbled and and everybody
was safe and and we were able to have a
good time but i mean
they were just good people you know you
never know what you're gonna get when
you start shooting a new movie and and
i'm huge fans of all of them and evan
and i hadn't seen each other since like
our nickelodeon days so that had been
like 10 years
so uh we had we had bumped into each
other like once in a while but but we
hadn't actually hung out and caught up
so that was really cool
what did you do did you guys work on the
show together at nickelodeon show
i was on true jackson well avin was on
um
not icarly um
the
the
victoria victorious victorious the
victoria justice one i think is
victorious
it's been a long ass time so yeah
oh but that's pretty cool i know you
both canadian that's awesome
um
so then when it comes to you know this
movie um how excited are you for fans of
the video games to see this version
i think that if you grew up on the video
games this movie is going to blow your
mind i mean as someone who grew up
playing them and is a big fan of the ip
i think that this is the movie
that that the fans have been waiting for
it is a true adaptation of resident evil
1 and 2. um if you haven't
you know played the games or seen the
movies and and you're new to resident
evil then it's a great origin story an
introduction to this world and you know
there's a reason resident evil has been
as big a
a phenomenon since 1996 when it came out
people love it and and this is a great
way for for a new audience to get into
it yeah well has your wife seen this
film yet
no she's gonna see it with me i i rented
out a theater in toronto for opening
weekend
oh my gosh it's so fun so she'll be in
the theater plugging your ears yeah
actually
i think she'll be okay because i'm in it
she'll be like oh it's not scary but
we'll got you
that's true that's awesome well so nice
getting to talk to you again yeah this
uh this movie really scared me so thanks
i love it thanks morgan thanks